zombie character classes we had captain
dead beard the crusty pirate zombie
who's been adrift for hundreds of years
we have super brains the genetically
engineered superhero zombie was amazing
hair and the unpredictable in with his
all-powerful Tzemach now today I would
like to formally introduce you to our
three all new plant classes first Rose
an all-powerful sorceress who can cast
spells trapping zombies in time snare
bubbles and even turn them into goats
exactly
this is Colonel corn now he can call in
buttery popcorn air support while mowing
down the enemy with his cob Busters and
finally citron a bounty-hunting orange
from the future called to fight the
zombies with his laser cannon and his
e'en peach but we're not just shaking
things up with new characters this is
the first garden warfare our fans have
been telling us that they want solo play
and we heard you loud and clear now
since the first garden warfare and
garden warfare 2 nolley can't you play
every game mode by yourself
we or with friends against the AI but
we're gonna take it one step further
with the backyard battleground a dynamic
hub unlike anything that you've seen in
pvz before the backyard the backyard
battleground is where you start every
game it's a living playground with so
much to do and discover before you ever
get into any modes or Maps you can take
on daily quests and challenges you can
even interact with your favorite PBZ
characters complete missions for crazy
days or dr. zomboss to uncover the
garden warfare 2 story you can even
invite up to 3 friends into your hub to
ignite battles all your own now when
you're ready to get into a game mode
your entire group can hop into a warp
gate and transport as a party making it
even easier and more fun to play the
game with friends
now backyard battleground ADA this is an
entirely new way to experience garden
warfare in the pvz universe but speaking
of universes get ready for two awesome
worlds to collide next year garden
warfare is known for spoofing games that
we love and one of my all-time favorites
poof's was grass effect so so we had a
thought what if we could turn grass
effect into more than a spoof and what
if we could partner with our friends at
Bioware to bring the amazing
intergalactic technology of Mass Effect
into the crazy over-the-top world of
plants vs. zombies I mean dr. zomboss
loves technology right
interlocking ceramic plate armor an
extremely Handy's omni-tool and a
factory-installed toaster oven this is
the amazing grass effect z-7 mech
combining the look and feel of Mass
Effect with the humor of PVC
now dr. Thomas is obviously very excited
I may be the most excited mass effect is
one of my all-time favorite games and I
can tell you right now I'm gonna have
some fun I'm running through garden
warfare 2 in this amazing new character
now anyone who pre-order his garden
warfare 2 will get their hands on their
very young z7 mech at launch this game
taps into the heart of who we are as a
studio to deliver the most fun crazy and
over-the-top shooter experience that we
possibly can and it's coming to you in
spring 2016 and now I'm gonna leave you
with the first look at gameplay from a
brand new map garden warfare is going to
space our plant heroes are on the moon
attempting to stop doctors on buffs from
creating a permanent solar eclipse with
a giant magnet I assure you it's just as
fun and weird as it sounds so thank you
and please enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]